when you watch TV now who makes you
laugh you know everybody makes me laugh
I appreciate how much effort goes into
what I know oh they're all good I mean
there's so many good comedians this John
Mulaney is great he's really good I saw
this kid Bob Berman the other day I
thought he was really good he's young
he's 26 now there's a lot of really
funny comics out there and a lot of
funny women now you know nice stuff yeah
there are only a few and now it's it's
it's well they're probably still more
male comedians but there are certainly a
lot of female comics and the jokes are
interchangeable
you know you know when I started it was
all about the way you dressed or like
Phyllis Diller really good writer really
funny comedian but she had to make
herself unattractive to be appealing to
the TV on it she's actually a very
attractive woman you have the crazy hair
so people would do ugly jokes what you
know just yeah but she wouldn't have to
do that now she could just be a comedian
you know talking about comedians it's a
very interesting time in the world to
run out in 2018 and what is politically
correct what's the right thing to do
what's the wrong thing to say it's
there's so much right now it's not
really that hard but comedians have to
be extra careful don't they or do they
know the rules just change and you need
to either go with the rules hmm oh you
don't you fall by the wayside I mean I
think it's fair to say 30 years ago gay
jokes homosexual jokes are a part of
every comedians Act they had some sort
of a kind of impression or something
well that went out of favor fairly
quickly if you did that now you get
booed off the stage and then the same
thing with women the dumb blonde jokes
that kind of stuff all the kind of stuff
women drivers whatever it might be you
know so you just learned do you just
follow what's going on you pay attention
to the world and you write your jokes
accordingly I mean you can turn it
around you know you put the laughs on
the harasser rather than the her a see
you know you can still do it I don't
find it that hard you know
is there anything off limits for you
when you do your comedy well I mean it's
it's off limits I mean I watched some
comics like I'll turn on HBO specials
and you literally have to be a
gynecologist to follow the Act I go what
where is that so it's it's I don't know
you know what it is I'm sort of the
old-school
comics now find an audience and play to
that crowd right my thing was always you
just try to put yourself in places where
you don't think you will work to see
what works I mean I once I booked myself
into Oral Roberts University just to see
if I could play it and all they said was
we don't like any sex jokes just no sex
jokes political stuff fine everything
they were great they were great audience
they just didn't want sex jokes okay
that's what they're paying for
that's what you give me my follow up on
that Roseanne Barr recently like I mean
I want to get your opinion on that like
they don't handle the situation with her
tweet that was racial racist towards
Jared I mean I mean I think itself
I've known Roseanne for 30 years I don't
like to denigrate other comics I mean
obviously there's a problem there and
it's mental I think she's really
troubled you know I don't know if they
feel sorry
you know you're at a certain place in
show business if you don't know that by
now I'm sorry you deserve what you get I
mean I don't know anybody knows not to
do that
you know like the Papa John pizza guy
okay what are you doing you know come on
I mean it's just sort of common sense
you know there's certain things you
don't say in front of your grandmother
okay just think of the audience is your
grandmother I mean I mean yeah I don't
know what was doing I I mean I hope she
finds peace somehow she seems really
troubled and and I think she's got some
interview this week with Sean Hannity I
don't like to see ya people get Mego
durin to say and then now she'll say
something else outrageous and so what
does it do now it just makes people sad
or miserable mm-hmm you know we have so
much of this like in the states now the
economy is actually quite good but
everybody's bad because of environmental
things and you know the divisive nature
of politics ah yes it's just here to
tell jokes just tell the jokes what
about Jimmy Fallon when he had Trump on
a people were criticizing him for like
just humanizing him and like making him
relatable do you think that was a
mistake
well obviously it was I mean I think it
hurt Jimmy but yeah Jimmy's a very nice
guy and you know there are people who
will try to incite an argument and then
people always try to find the best in a
situation and I think that's what he was
trying to do and it backfired but I
don't think it doesn't change them but I
mean it you know I always look at the
attention what is the intention here
because there are people that say things
that are mean or you know like I watched
the Sacha Baron Cohen thing mm-hmm and I
kind of went it just seemed to me I mean
some of those people seem like nice
people look up mislead I mean obviously
he exposed some real he did yeah it's
just not Myka well like we used to
jaywalking on the street I would say to
people look I'm gonna ask you some
questions and comfortable this okay and
then if they hang themselves oh that's
great but I give them all the facts
here's all the infant you know wouldn't
pretend to be somebody else and get them
to say something embarrassing
it's just a different way to turn it you
don't like his show it's not my kind of
thing I can appreciate it
I understand it I like comedy it makes
me feel good after I watch it does it I
just feel like oh I like him
yeah you know to me like these some of
those people are so awful they'll hang
themselves without your help you don't
need to Gilda Lily as they say you know
just ask them just get them going and oh
man this guy is awful
to trick them into saying it then make
some people feel empathy for them which
to me backfires
so like the guy who's screaming the
n-word and all kind of stuff that guy
probably would have done it anyway but
by tricking him now you there are people
who go oh gee I felt sorry for the other
night I don't like that guy I think he's
a horrible person I don't want to feel
any empathy more you know what's a fun
show to watch what's a Jay Leno's Garage
why thank you then say yeah that's are
you like having the best time ever like
it's a lot of our celebrity nerds and
you know we get a lot of so because I
call them up and I go look I don't care
about your cocaine bust I don't care to
your movie bomb I don't care about your
divorce what you drive okay and they
show up and I don't I don't break that I
don't go into so tell what happened with
you and so it's up you know because I
don't I don't care it's nothing like
business I don't care you know so and
that's what makes it funny